[Laughter]
all right you could ease this what's
called deadly fun are you having fun yet
critters try to have a little more fun
this time for you maybe I could have a
little more fun if I wasn't doing that
particular character Wow have fun okay
you like to be on this lovely mother red
Oh No our lovely legs Indiana don't like
to have fun alright so gently fall
gently growl oh you like my ballerina ow
Oh sward throwing hook oh come on in the
back oh no Joe obstacle course in red
and blue how delightful for me oh I
didn't even read what that said dork
dork back mark mark mark mark mark can't
get me I'm too balancing on my son's
head there we go well okay then at least
my son is alive that's really all that
matters right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay oh it's one of these I was
wondering what was going on here wait a
minute what am I supposed to do
oh no the tongue is swallowing me 100%
impossible I'm thinking this might
actually be correct
oh no joke crazy sward bro what this
doesn't help me I have to grab like I
have to grab a bunch you put too many
swartz oh if I could just get my arms up
there we go huh don't know where that's
going
noob vending machine whoa okay oh I'm
gonna be a candy bar alright let's try
this again without the whole dying thing
that's my favorite part
get back
oh my goodness
[Music]
there's so little room for error on this
one it's got to be perfect if your
crotch even scrapes it by the hardest
level ever
well I beat the one that was 100%
impossible so I don't see okay so I got
a four off those arrows whoo-hoo and now
that I got that out of the way this
should be no problem you gonna get me
this time oh you thought that heart I'm
just gonna sit here in this corner where
you don't play my time for the winner's
circle
[Music]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you liked the
video and want to see more why not
subscribe today wanna help the channel
grow leave a like and if your favorites
will share with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see in the next video